okay chair ah thank you well
good evening everybody and uh welcome to
our meeting of health scrutiny committee
and special welcome to uh our presenters
this evening and also to
any members of the public who may be
watching the recording live or
um at a future point of their watching
the recording
and i'd just like to introduce myself
i'm karen barkley and chair of health
scrutiny committee
and we also have councillor taylor who
is a vice chair
and our meeting this evening comprises
of members of health scrutiny committee
officers and executive members of a
council and officers
from a number of the council's partner
organizations
so and welcome to everybody and just two
points for housekeeping if that's okay
um first of all please could everybody
mute their microphone if they're not
speaking just because that stops any
kind of sounds coming through
making it difficult to hear and if you
would like to ask a question
please just pop a note in the chat and
and i'll pick that up i'll make sure
that i don't miss
and miss anybody out so um
with that uh done and perhaps you can
start with the main agenda
and um attendance is our first item so
and fabio do we have any apologies for
this evening's meeting
uh we have not received any apologies
and no counsel mrs sadat is trying to
join our meeting now and saw counselors
later
okay fantastic that's great well
hopefully they'll come through very soon
okay moving on to agenda item number two
it's the minutes
um we do we know that we do need to make
a correction
um to our minutes but if there are any
other things any members would like to
point out please do but
um is it yes um would you like to make a
correction counselor yes thank you and i
made the declaration of interest being
the trustee of traffic
domestic abuse services which was
discussed at the meeting thank you
so are we able to amend our minutes
accordingly
oh i will chair that's absolutely
fantastic and with that
are people happy to agree that it's a
correct record
yeah fantastic thank you so much just
before we move on from the mid
from the minutes to the decorations of
interest just to point out that at our
previous meeting gender item five
and it covered access um to primary
healthcare services
in trafford and and at the end of that
discussion we didn't actually
raise the issue of um carrying on
our discussions on that in the in the
next municipal year it would be quite
nice to receive an update on that
so i just wondered if members of
committee would be happy for
us to write to the ccg just to ask for a
follow-up at some point
and which we can agree with the ccg to
get an update on that
for the next municipal year the
committee happy with that
okay thank you very much indeed that's
very
very welcome thank you just two other
little things to mention as well
uh since our last meeting and and those
minutes two documents have been
published which members might be
interested in taking a look at
certainly really important for the work
of the committee going forward next year
and first of all the joint strategi
joint strategic needs assessment for
trafford
has just recently been published
obviously it's an update from the last
one so
it's the most recent one it's brand new
so if members would like to receive a
copy of that please
do let us know and also the corporate
equality strategy has recently been
approved
by the executive as well and and
again that's a document that's really
important particularly given our
interest in inequalities tonight as well
so again that is something that members
can receive a link to
and if you're interested so please do um
let
fabiola know if you'd like to receive
copies of those okay
so uh moving on to an agenda item number
three it's declarations of interest
does anybody have any declarations they
would like to make
no okay that's fantastic thank you very
much
public questions fabiola have we
received any public questions and no
public questions received chair
okay fantastic okay so and with that
moving on to
um our first main topic of the evening
which is tackling health inequalities in
trafford
with a focus on diabetes and just a tiny
tiny introduction to that we
obviously know that the pandemic has
horribly exposed
um the inequalities that exist and
in health and in our populations and not
just exposed it really added to it and
made them even worse so obviously it's
something that health scrutiny committee
is concerned about we know that the
council and its partners are
committed to um equality and we thought
that we would spend
our final meeting of the year looking at
um
two different types of circumstance
where the council may be able to show us
how they're working towards
reducing those inequalities the first
being diabetes obviously a clinical
condition
and the second housing which we know is
a really important
social determinant of health so i'm
going to be associating both of those
topics this evening they're really
important they're both impacted
on and impact on healthy health
so and we would really welcome hearing
from our presenters this evening
on what the inequalities are how they
exhibit themselves in trafford
and what the council and the partners
are doing to reduce those inequalities
so thank you so much for our first
report it was a really detailed report
on diabetes
really really interesting i didn't know
that the prevalence of diabetes was so
high i found that really shocking
and and so obviously we welcome hearing
from you this evening perhaps you could
just highlight
the areas of concern and how you're
addressing would really appreciate that
so welcome to our speakers on this topic
thank you
thanks very much councillor um so i
think you've
you've said the first thing that i was
going to say that kovid has
exposed and exacerbated the existing
inequalities that we have
um and in trafford it's increased the
gap between our most and least
disadvantaged communities and there's a
clear social gradient
in prevalence of diabetes and the risk
factors that contribute it
and an estimated one in five adults
either have diabetes or pre-diabetes
and i have to say i i was with you i was
actually surprised that when you combine
the two together
um how prevalent both those conditions
were
and so there are key programs which we
have to support prevention of diabetes
the main one being the national diabetes
prevention program
we've got lots of capacity within the
program
and between public health and ccg we've
got a joint action plan
to try and ensure that we utilize this
capacity because
unfortunately we went live not long
before
um lockdown won in march last year
and at that point we also were just
about to start the engagement with
some of our priority communities
particularly those in the north of
trafford
and so moving forward our priority is
engagement
with practices in the north primary care
network
and also working with vcse sector within
the north community
collective to make sure that we've
really got that engagement and we start
to
drive referrals and use some of our
capacity
once people um start on the national
diabetes prevention program we've got a
really good
um conversion rate of referrals and
people taking up the program
and we have good outcomes when people
access the programme
but we need to ensure that we've got
that targeted uptake in our communities
of greatest need
because what we don't know is actually
is our good referral rates and good
outcomes
because actually we're getting the
people who are the most um
the most motivated joining that program
in the first place
we've also got a number of our weight
management services which we're piloting
and our healthy lifestyle service and
again
we're targeting these to the communities
where we have greatest need
with different variety of programs on
offer to try and support
um different communities to engage um
our key early screening occurs via nhs
health checks
and one of the things we're doing moving
forward is making sure these are
more targeted so we're rather
necessarily inviting everyone eligible
we're really focusing
um that in a targeted way to make sure
that again the people most in need are
taking up their health check
and also that they're carried out more
effectively and
to make sure that we're actually
following the the process really
accurately and making sure we're
um identifying the risks for people
having those health checks
and also to reduce some of the pressure
on primary care where health checks are
delivered
and anything which makes it easier for
them and more targeted will be of
benefit
the development and reshaping the
diabetes pathway is also a priority
and ensuring that clinical management of
patients with type 2 diabetes is
provided locally and is really
accessible in community settings because
again we know that's
variable at the moment the the aim
particularly from
the clinical side is to get back to
business as usual within primary and
secondary care
working alongside the long-term
conditions group that's part of the
local care organization
and making sure that there's a real
route map back to community and
outpatient's focus
and kind of underpinning that we need to
make sure we're looking at all the
factors that impact on health
inequalities alongside those
key behavior change programs like weight
management and
national diabetes prevention program we
need to make sure we're looking at
policy the environment both physical and
social environments
cultural norms and beliefs and we've
identified some really clear actions
where we need to take that action which
should hopefully deliver the outcomes
and the impact that we want to see
hopefully that was uh
a brief overview of everything that was
in the paper um
and obviously any questions thank you
very much
jane that's really really helpful um i
didn't ellen did you want to add
anything to what jane has said
no just to really um commend the fact
that we're actually being able to get on
with this work
now it's um jane and i'd also
actually take the opportunity to
introduce jilla burgess allen
who's our new public health consultant
to the health scrutiny committee
so jilla is now leading this work um and
very ably supported as you can see by
jane but it has been
over this last year i think the public
health team have been very distracted by
covid
as has primary care but jane has been
doing a fantastic job to make sure that
we keep this weight management work on
track
because it's absolutely critical to our
recovery particularly as we know that we
are starting to see
obesity rates increase in trafford um
following the the various lockdowns and
over this last year
so it's one of our absolute priority
works from us from a public health
perspective
thank you thank you very much um and uh
welcome uh to committee or is there
anything you would like to add at all
thanks chair um just to say i'm
delighted to be uh
joining the team and um yeah just to
reiterate i think what eleanor has said
i think now is a really opportune
time for us to focus on our
recovery as we um emerge slowly from
this latest lockdown and you know i
think that the paper
uh really clearly sets out what our
strengths are and what the challenges
are
and i think it's also clear how we plan
to address those so
i'm really keen to be involved in taking
that forward
okay thank you thank you so much do
members of committee have any questions
for our i guess
yes um if you just pop it in the chat
then i'll be able to
make sure you you aren't missed so but i
saw counsellor canola
you'd like to ask a question yeah i was
trying to put it in the chat but it's
not letting me type it
um i just wanted to ask for some clarity
about what we're doing
um regarding um recording ethnicity
because
you know such high 80s um
that we haven't got the ethnicity of the
people
who've recorded full stop i know it's
higher than greater manchester's just
wondering what action is being done
about that
so this is my complete obsession and has
been for some time
and councilor lloyd i think has been at
some of the meetings where i've been
expressing my disappointment at the
quality of some of the data recording
i think one of the um if you can
talk about benefits from covert i think
one of the things has been
that um some of the things that were
perhaps a little bit hidden
have become much more apparent to a lot
more people so the ccg have an action
plan to make sure that they started
work with the gps to improve the
recording of the ethnicity
the hospital systems tend to be quite
good and we're also looking at how we
can
make those links back into primary care
so that we can get that done
quickly and easily but they they have a
there is a program in place with the ccg
to improve the
um the recording it's included as well
in our equality strategy which is joint
between this council and the ccg so that
is one of the key actions for the ccg
because without accurate data we really
are going to struggle to be
able to demonstrate that we aren't
discriminating um
and this is you know we have to be able
to show that we're meeting our equality
duties
so it's something i take extremely
seriously i know councillor slater has
also been at ccg governing body meetings
where we've had these discussions and i
think also through
as i say through the work with the
equality strategy
it's really a key focus
would you like to come back on that uh
council canola
no okay thank you okay council council
hartley please
sorry doctor um sorry councilor barclays
okay if i just say something you know
now we've got yes yeah of course
councillor says any problem
i couldn't with the it isn't working
very well so apologies
that's coming on my work's laptop
because i couldn't get in on any council
traffic council equipment and what i
wanted to say was with the opportunity
of the census
we should have you know a real
opportunity now to be able to record
ethnicity and all and other protect
characteristics
in that in that information so encourage
as many people as you possibly can
to um complete the census information
you know i know that everybody's
required to fill it in but actually
drill down into some of that um uh
protected characteristic information
would be really really helpful going
forward
karen you're on mute
thank you could i just ask why is it so
difficult to record ethnicity what's the
actual barrier to recording it
thank you i think it's historic
um and i think it's that other parts of
the
the gp systems some of the recording
isn't terribly easy to do
and they in hospitals now there's much
more focus on getting everybody to check
all of their data anytime you go in for
an appointment
whereas in primary care possibly because
of the way that the appointments are
structured
and the the amount of time and speed of
getting people through the appointments
um i think just there has been a slight
custom and practice of not perhaps
making sure that they get everything
at the first patient registration and
then
it it just drifts so i think um
the the the issue has been that there's
a backlog to get through
and we're working with the ccg to think
about how they can
most um most effectively meet that
backlog
and meet their legal meet those
requirements but as i say there is um
absolute willingness on the ccg
and a real in a real um real enthusiasm
to engage with this now
so i'm i'm absolutely delighted by that
with the census information that will be
so valuable as well because obviously
our ccg population gives us our
registered population
but many of our residents live in other
part
registered with gps outside trafford so
we need to know for our residents
what the ethnic background for all of
our residents are as well as for our
for our populations one of the things
that's coming out
with um because obviously since the last
census was done
um we've had quite a you know you would
expect to see quite a few changes in
various bits that are demographics
and so we're in some categories now
we're getting over 100
of people vaccinated um which we suspect
is more because we don't actually have
accurate
population data rather than um you know
our estimates on some of our populations
and now sufficiently out that with the
very high levels of
uh vaccination being given we've seen
some groups having 108
vaccinated which is very good result
okay oh okay so thank you that
is a really really important question
from counselor canola so thank you for
uh answering that so fully
uh councillor hartley please
thank you chair um i had i had one
question and then i've just noticed an
observation as well which just links
back to
what you mentioned earlier chair about
the uh access to primary care and the
need to revisit that it's just
it's probably just worth noting that in
terms of the referrals to the
to the national program i know there was
a problem with the letters going out
from um practices in the north and and
that was just quite
um that was quite telling to me because
practice closes
and i think you get the impression that
practice closes the patients gets
transferred to another practice
it's all fine but this is the sort of
thing i suppose that that gets missed so
um
you know i just thought i was worth
noting the impact of a practice closure
can can run can run deep um the question
i had was
about the health checks and the
invitations for health checks
um and it's do we know
why so trafford scores um
sort of poorly in terms of the
proportion of people invited
and so sorry i'm looking at the graphs
that are on page 16
and i might not be studying the graphs
fully but
it looks like some authorities are
getting 100 bolton rochdale wigan
i don't know if that's right but
certainly a lot of authorities are
scoring a lot a lot higher very 89
etcetera
and i just wonder if we know if we did
any work with those authorities to try
and understand how they get
such high invitation rates so how are
they getting that right and we are
not getting it as right i suppose thank
you
i can i can take that one purely because
having
i worked in wigan for nearly 10 years
before i joined trafford a few years ago
so
they have um and happened today they
have a very different model of
delivering health checks so whereas ours
are delivered through primary care
in wigan it's actually a separately
commissioned service delivered by a
community interest company
so um and if i remember correctly they
i think they have well similar to us
they have performance by results but
their
sole focus and their their entirety of
that part of their organization is
focused on
on inviting people for health checks and
they're very proactive
it's not part of the business as usual
for
within primary care so that that may be
one reason why
wigan in particular is so high i have
said i don't know
in terms of the other two bolton and
rochdale um
in terms of what they do but it's
certainly worth something that we can
look into see how
how their model differs and how they
reach 100
can i come in and help you there jane
you certainly can hi it's it's my job
i'm sorry to join you later and i'm
afraid i've got another meeting to go to
shortly as well but
and jane is right we do not commission
an additional service we've had to
um try and get the gps to
perform these checks within the limited
time and budget they have available
and that links back to trafford ccg's
historic poor financial position we
haven't had
the money is available to commission a
lot of services that
the others do unfortunately um the way
health care is funded at a chcg level um
is based on a formula of of that is
mainly deprivation-led
and unfortunately trafford as a borough
has a
pockets of deprivation very small
proportion
um and we ahead of most of the other
boroughs in greater manchester ended up
in financial difficulties
in and and effectively that left us
without the flexibility to commission
these additional services as it became
apparent that they would have been
appropriate
is that okay counselor hartley yes
yes thank you no that's really useful
okay fantastic uh so the next question
is councillor haddad please
um hi um yeah i was just wondering um in
terms of
um the diabetes and high prevalence
rate of diabetes in psychiatric um
uh patients and i wondered you know
given the inequalities what have you
plans around focusing on this group or
how would you perhaps think about
addressing it
who would be able to answer uh
counselors i'll i'll start and then i'm
sure mark and jane will come in but
i think um what we're seeing
particularly with people with serious
mental illness
is we know in trafford we have really
high rates of premature mortality in
that group
and we're particularly um we're we're an
outlier compared to many other areas
so people with serious mental illness
the impact of mental illness is one of
the things that we've been trying to
focus on
through our health and wellbeing board
work and particularly around that
healthy life expectancy
so one of the the the physical health of
people with serious mental illness is
something we've been really trying to
focus on
working with the ccg on making sure that
people
in that group get the physical health
checks and so on that they require and
it comes back to some of these
conversations
about the health check offer and making
sure that we do get that
that offer made to the people who are
most likely to benefit for it
who are often the people who are least
likely to come forward unless you really
make the offer in the way that they they
want to take it
so again it's it's using all of um
all of our if you like our influencing
through
through different groups including
working with gmmh to make sure that
people's physical health
is is properly addressed we we know this
group have
a very high level of smoking as well
compared to the general population
so i think with any of this it's
thinking about all of these health
behaviors
in the round um and making sure that we
give a really good strong offer
to our people who are suffering from
mental illness
um and to the so that we we start
narrowing the gap
between that group and the rest of the
population and i'm sure
mark will come in on that
yeah i mean it's very timely from my
perspective
you know we're thinking about the start
of a new financial year
um hopefully a situation where we're
going through a recovery
process for um following covid and it
that not being the
raison d'etre for health services
anymore um
and that recovery um and kovid have
highlighted the fact that we need to
focus
on addressing the inequalities you know
it's been an aspiration for many years
um but realistically we haven't really
achieved very much
in changing those inequalities
um kovid has really brought that home to
everybody
so it is far easier for eleanor in
in her persuasion of the rest of the
system
to actually get that understood and get
the changes so
the work we're doing in preparation for
recovery
that's not just recovery of secondary
care services but gps as they
move out of the reactive phase of the
pandemic into
you know trying to pick up more of the
business as usual and do
more long-term condition work is to
focus that
on the areas that will have the biggest
impact and that is about
addressing the inequalities so that you
know
is fundamentally the
the principle that went to our primary
care committee only yesterday
um for our approach to to recovery and
how we're going to work with all our gp
practices
to take this forward
uh thank you dr jarvis um council haddad
did you want to follow
any of that up are you happy with that
no thank you for that it's just um yeah
that's very helpful you know best of
luck
with that thank you okay thank you
councillor taylor you had a question
my question was actually the exact
question i was going to ask was
actually asked by council hartley so
thank you for that but
i just wanted to say thank you so much
to ellen and to jane for producing this
report because it's so comprehensive
and um it's so timely and it's so
appropriate and i'm glad it really
our work and our thoughts about this
sort of really harmonized with the
the vision of the ccg and and public
health going forward
into the recovery period but thank you
very much and a lot of work
is ongoing and thank you for pulling it
all together in this report for us jane
we really do appreciate it
thank you councillor taylor councillor
lloyd
the diabetes has been known for a long
time
um and the effects of it and i was
interesting about the fact that it's
commissioning services
and they haven't been commissioned in
the past in the way we could because
of problems with the cash that we
receive or the ccg received from the
government
and recognizing that is there any other
ways that we can try
and um target the population really to
get the tests that they need
because some of it some of it could
be possibly done outside of gp practices
or can it that's the one question and
the other question i would like to ask
is about
um the fact that the north borders my
side
um in manchester and some
residents are actually registered with a
manchester gps
can we do any sharing if if that's
possible
particularly i'm thinking of the bme uh
community
thank you so i'll try and answer that
for you judith
um firstly i'm i'm sorry if i gave the
wrong impression the
the problems with commissioning
additional services was
about the learning disabilities and smi
groups
and those health checks not about
diabetic care
um the funding has not been an issue for
diabetic care
um jane's paper um or hello newspaper
whoever's got the ownership that we all
contributed to
and explains that historically
we had a secondary care department at
traffic general
who liked to look after all the
diabetics but that's not necessarily in
their best interest
and nationally the model is that gps are
actually very good at
diabetic care for the majority it's only
the complex
ones that need hospital care um
so so there isn't a problem with
commissioning the diabetic
services it's where the people have
other complicating factors like learning
difficulties
or um serious mental illness
where the additional commission may not
have happened
so yes you know diabetic care the model
nationally is that the majority of that
will
occur within primary care i'm actually
we've got
you know good experienced practitioners
available within trafford to provide
most of that and we've got good support
within mft where it is needed for most
of our
diabetic care so that was your first
question i've just forgotten the second
part of it the second question i think
eleanor brought it up about the
manchester uh about the people who are
in manchester
and i just wondered if there was shared
care with um
perhaps particularly i was thinking with
the bae me community yeah
um we're doing we're doing more and more
work manchester
because so the gp practices
are managed at the moment by each ccg
the
management of the gp contracts is
delegated to the ccg so the practice is
based
um within trafford and managed by
trafford and the magistrates management
managed by manchester but we're doing
far more joint working because
all of our patients use the same
secondary care services with mft
you know so we we've had daily meetings
through a lot of the pandemic with
with manchester to address issues
we've stepped that down to weekly but
we've had some recent conversations
about the
the manchester and trafford cell that
it's called about whether that continues
and what the benefits are and we want we
actually want to build on those improved
relationships so
the learning about um vaccination
in the um and the
hesitancy that has been an issue in the
north of the borough
is exactly the same for while arranging
more side in those bordering communities
in manchester and we've been sharing
those resources
to try and work together to address
because the community isn't split by the
division
between traffic and manchester the
community actually sits across
it so we're trying to work hard to
address
the community as that by working
together
okay thank you thank you for that and
yes um i think it's better for gps
to be looking after their patients
because they they
they can do it just as well yeah and
nearer home
thank you absolutely
thank you councillor lloyd uh counselor
dr carr
thank you um i just wanted to clarify
um just going back to the health checks
because um
this really detailed and helpful report
has um obviously highlighted
that um patients in the north of the
borough are
who are in most need are not being
invited
um for health checks at all and
therefore definitely aren't attending
them
because they've not been invited in the
first place um
and we've already clarified
some of the reasons behind that is
because uh
currently that's because the gps
themselves are having to do that work
which is in contrast to maybe other
boroughs in gm
and but i just wanted to really drill
down into what we're actually going to
do about that
because obviously as it stands those gp
surgeries are not going to get any more
money
so the situation i mean it's really good
that we've
highlighted it as a problem and that we
want to address it but i just wondered
how are we going to actually do that
because
just leaving it to the same situation
it's going to
you know the same problem is going to
happen in perpetuity
so i just wanted to be really clear are
we going to
put you know particularly in areas of
deprivation are we going to look at
commissioning
that separately in the same way that
maybe wigan does
or how are we going to address it
because leaving it to the
gp surgeries when those gp surgeries are
much less financially successful in the
north of the borough is clearly
not going to be effective so
so if i so we've got two sets of funding
for health checks
um we've got the funding that's core
funding within the ccg which uh
and that's where the sit the health
checks would link to serious mental
illness and learning disabilities sits
and then we've got the health checks
money that sits within the local
commission services
which sits within the council so what
we're doing with the council
element of funding is absolutely taking
those points that you make
that we're not seeing that equity of
provision and we're not seeing the
impact in the reach of our health checks
in the populations that we most want
to um to be finding finding
in fact this was some work we were going
to we would start we started doing
um just over a year ago and then it's
been completely blown off course by the
um pandemic so it's been put on hold for
a year
jilla one of the pieces of work that
jilla will be doing
is reviewing our whole health checks
offer working with jane and other people
in her team to make sure that we've got
a really robust offer
that targets the funding where we know
the greatest need is
so we're really going to be looking at
our health checks offer in a very
different way
also we're working closely obviously
with the ccg
on the whole every contact counts and
i'm working with the ccg
on their work on their health on the
health checks for people serious mental
illness and learning disabilities
but absolutely take your point at the
moment the way we're
funding the the way that the health
checks are being delivered
is not giving us the outcome that we
need for our population
and um we we have been looking at how we
can improve that
and as i say one of one of jill's first
tasks
is to try and make sure that we we turn
this around
working with jane and others in her team
i don't know jill if you want to say
anything on that
thanks helena sorry just took me a
moment to get off mute then
yes uh absolutely um we
are looking to move towards a far more
targeted
um delivery model uh for health checks
um and we want to redress
those inequalities um we've currently
got a model of health checks that as
says does not meet uh the health needs
of our population and potentially could
widen inequalities we won't need it to
do the opposite
so um yeah it will be a complete rethink
and i think we might well have
um perhaps different tiers of delivery
so there might be
uh some kind of health check light if
you like which can be undertaken
online um obviously there's digital
inclusion aspects to that that we'd want
to address
um and then we would have the full
health check
offer which would be targeted uh both
at those people who appear to have risk
factors
when they do um the basic health check
and also um those geographical and other
um equity groups
that we would want to target so that's
that's what we're working to
develop at this time
dr jarvis did you want to add anything
yeah um
again the general practice in the north
of borough
on the nhs contract is actually better
funded than in the south
because the gp funding is based on
deprivation as well
so per head of population that gp looks
after
the funding to support that is greater
in areas with deprivation
so that's not a reason why general
practice in the north borough has been
under pressure it's it's more being um
the um
what's the word um the disruption
caused by a couple of practice closures
and the lists having been to be changed
side
uh it moved around and also there's been
some recruitment issues although
over the last year that has improved
significantly
um so so the
it's more the disruption so i i do think
it's realistic
to expect the performance in those
practices in the north to improve going
forwards
because they've had a lot to deal with
over the last two or three years but
they should be stabilizing
and in a position to make those
improvements um you know we're not
asking to do more of the same with the
same people
there has been reason why there is
opportunity for that to change
would you like to come back counselor dr
um i mean
yeah i i guess it is just more
challenging to
run a gp surgery effectively in a
deprived area in a hugely deprived area
which is why we've seen some of these gp
practices fail though
um so yes although the funding
you know just like uh running a school
in a deprived area you know there will
be more people premium children
and and likewise there are more funding
but there's a lot more to do
and i'm not i'm
just not entirely reassured about how
this is going to get better
um because uh yes we've got
more stability with our gp surgeries now
that's
that's definitely good but this is a
long story
that is not a new situation for us in
trafford
in terms of um performance in our
in our most deprived areas so
um i've heard still just a lot of
rhetoric about it being recognized as a
problem and it's really good that it's
being recognized as a problem
i'm just not clear how it's going to be
addressed
other than going to those gp practices
and saying do
do better which i think
yeah which i think um i think we are
moving
away from that so i think some of the
offers we will be giving will be
about what do we do if the gp practice
doesn't turn out to be the best place
for people to go
and how do we get the outcomes we need
certainly with the money that the local
authority has for health checks
we will be looking at targeting that to
make sure that we get the uptake we need
in the populations we need
we do have some practices who choose not
to do health checks and we
we make alternative provision in those
cases
already so um i i think
as as mark said um this last year has
been very difficult for everyone the
year before there was a lot of
disruption in primary care
particularly in the north um and and
some
you know some notable changes in
practices and a lot of
a lot of turbulence really for the the
practices
but with that increased stability and i
think with the
you know we do have some excellent gps
in the north and with the focus that
kobe has given
i think there is a real appetite to make
things change
now and we we've i'm certainly having
conversations with people
much more easily than i was having maybe
two years ago
it does feel like there's been a change
um
generally across the whole of trafford
about understanding
what the impact of covet has been and
what we need to be doing differently to
address that
and as jilla says we'll be looking at
trying to make sure that our health
check
offer is really targeted and is probably
a very light touch for a lot of the
population
but that we're able to use some search
mechanisms within gp practice data
so that we can see which of the people
that we really want to get hold of
um and and and make sure that we target
and follow up with those people those
could be people for example we might you
know one of the searches might be if
you're a 50 year old man who hasn't been
seen by a gp for 20 25 years when
there's a
number of those those are the sort of
people we definitely want to be getting
hold of
if you're somebody who's been back and
forth to the gp and we know that there's
reason you know that the the gp
has no concerns um we'll be taking a
lighter touch
with those people so it's really trying
to make sure that we
we use the the information that the gps
hold to get really good stratification
of our population so that we can target
the pro
the services appropriately
which is which is a new approach yeah i
i didn't want to underestimate the
challenges we have in some areas of the
borough from
from a care perspective um
and it's difficult to quantify the
culture change that we've experienced
through this
um that as as ellen has just described
the attitude
to addressing these inequalities is
completely different to anything i've
experienced
in nearly 30 years of a gp we've paid
lip service to it
much as you might think i'm doing today
however what has
changed is that culture and people
wanting to
actually make a difference and do
something different so so
you know we're early in the journey of
what those changes are actually going to
be
but i do feel that there's a um you know
there's been a significant change from
that perspective
are you happy with that counselor dr
carr yes happy with that response okay
thank you very much for um really
exploring that issue for us
uh councillor taylor had another
question i'm fred i'm gonna have to
leave
really appreciate you attending the
second meeting
thank you very much okay thank you thank
you
um it's just to make that a little bit
further
that the question of uh by um counselor
dr carr
um not only is the north of the borough
the most
deprived part of the world it's the most
culturally diverse part of the borough
as well and i think
um any um targeted
outreach to to try and encourage people
to to engage with health checks not only
just to ensure that they are invited but
needs to be culturally um sensitive
and and appropriate you know um
i'm not suggesting how how that should
be but
um i i think um and something you
highlighted in the report jane was
uh thinking about cultural norms and
beliefs
and um you know people depending on
their cultural backgrounds may engage
with with services in a variety of
different ways and
um i believe that needs um exploring
doesn't it
um and to ensure that uptake you know
there may be a number of different
models that are are out there to ensure
that people do engage it's not always
necessarily come to your gp practice
um i don't know what what is necessarily
the right way but i think that's
something that
um particularly in my own borough i know
it's
at my borough my award and you know it
really is i mean it's a huge
strength and um asset to the world that
it is so diverse but also it can be
um challenging and problematic that um
people don't always access the services
as they are currently offered so i think
that's something to
to really to consider and the second
thing is um
you know we've asked a lot of questions
and this is really you know it's very
sort of promising start
would you be willing i'm sure you would
to to come back and and report on
progress maybe in in a few months time
or
in a little bit later on in the year
thank you yes absolutely absolutely we
will definitely come back and report
and i think um i think you're right
about you know the gp practice and so on
it's
some of these things can be over
medicalized obviously with diabetes
there are some particular
tests you need to do including the blood
test but we
we have actually if you like taken some
of our services out of the health
service because we feel that they're
better
um provided through the vcsc and outside
a medical model so if i
if i just hand back to jane to talk
about how how we've been looking at the
weight management
work a little bit differently and trying
to make it back into a behavior change
service that isn't necessarily
led through a health service response
yes there's a there's a couple of things
really to to mention here that
as eleanor said with things like the
national diabetes prevention program
um there doesn't need to be blood there
do need to be blood tests that are
carried out but there's also
um second routine through um know your
risks
know your risk score so one of the
pieces of work that i've been doing
recently is with
our third sector organizations who work
specifically with the bme community
and and engaging with those groups and
talking to them about the program
and explaining that there are there are
two routes in and
if you don't particularly want to go
down the go to gp and get a blood test
route
there's also a second routine where you
can do an online risk assessment and we
actually
with one of the groups we actually went
through that with the group and so that
they could see
um kind of how straightforward it is
really and you could you can self-refer
without the need to speak to a health
professional
and and the the other thing is as ellen
said we've
we recently commissioned some pilot
weight management programs which we've
been really targeting and using our
vcsc um partners to promote those
and one of the key parts of those weight
management programs was that we didn't
want to put any more
pressure on primary care to refer people
so they were all open
for self-referral which in some ways
makes it easier
because we don't have to worry about
people getting appointments or
you know not engaging with the health
service but it also makes it a little
bit harder in terms of targeting because
if we um put social media posts we need
to really target them to specific
audiences because we know
that um the probably the people who are
the most
um the most engaged and the most
conscious of their health will be the
ones that take those that offer up first
they're not the ones that we want to
necessarily engage in our program so
we've been work i've been working really
closely with them the traffic community
collective and the neighborhood leads in
in those priority areas and also working
with our social prescribing link workers
not just the ones based within primary
care but those based on adult social
care and within the third sector as well
to try and change the way that people
access some of those services and just
make them make it easier for people
um without having to jump through
through hoops trying to get into
programs which sometimes unfortunately
with some of the nationally commissioned
programs like the diabetes prevention
program
um and some of the the pilot programs
that uh
that have just um been been working on
across gm like the nhs low calorie diet
program
they require a certain amount of primary
care
engagement in order to access them so
what we've been focusing on from a
public health side is trying to
make that provision that doesn't require
that and make it more accessible for
people
so i hope that answers your question
yeah thank you jane and just a really
quick question before
we bring this um item to a close um one
of the things that struck me in the
report as well
as the invitations was also um
the kind of perhaps issues with the
education program and
the uptake of that and the delivery of
that and
how are we i mean obviously education is
so important it is
it's a disease that the patient needs to
know a lot about to manage for
themselves really keep themselves as
well as
they possibly can so how are we um going
to try and tackle the inequalities that
may well exist within that i mean
have we been able to identify who's
coming forward
um are we targeting the program because
obviously and i think there was
an issue about the accessibility of the
program for everybody
thank you uh yeah i can pick that
question up so
it's it's really variable across um
across trafford as with a lot of these
things some practices
have um 100 of the people that they
refer
will take the program up but they might
actually only be referring
three people so it's quite small numbers
so it's really difficult
to to kind of get a picture we probably
need to do a bit more digging into that
data because there's an awful lot of
data there
broken down by practice level but that
certainly an innate would enable
us to then um make sure that we again
we're working with those practices
to make sure that they're aware of the
offer and again it's more flexible now
as well so um there's not at the moment
there's no
structured education face-to-face that
but there is an online offer
and i think part of um the learning from
covid is that while the online offer
makes it accessible to
a certain proportion of the population
we do need to be aware there are those
who
digitally excluded and the return to
face to face
i think really needs to focus on those
people who who aren't engaging in that
online offer
so let's thank everybody and so jane and
ellen and
dr jarvis as well um angela and thank
you all
uh for bringing the report to us this
evening it's obviously
really important and obviously i think
we have picked up on a couple of things
that we would be most grateful
if you uh could return um with some
information in the future
and one or two members have suggested
maybe a written contribution
in six months time perhaps just looking
at the health invitation
the invitations with health checks also
i think um underpinning
everything really is more you know how
we're going to progress
the issue of collecting information on
ethnicity
if perhaps we could have that updated
because that closure does really and i
think
underpin everything really and perhaps
just a little bit more information about
the education programs the kind of maybe
a bit more data about who's receiving
those and
are we making sure that we're narrowing
down any inequalities if
any exists would be really really
helpful would would that be
okay were that acceptable yeah fantastic
very happy to do that oh fantastic thank
you very much mike did you want to ask a
question with your hand
oh oh mike's all mute
um
at least i don't send the tablet onto
the other side of the room like this
morning but attract someone
i'm wondering if there's any engagement
we can make with the um
the north practices uh because
a lot of the conversations revolved
around whether they are
doing things whether they've got the
capacity to do
more whether they um want to involve
i i just feel that in some ways
partly we're not including them and
they're very much of the
as a third party and partly we're
allowing them a little bit off the hook
and then
by not engaging with them directly i
wonder because they are major players in
this
um and despite you know everything
they've had
a little bit of uh investment in the
practices as such
as so it would be quite useful to be
able to talk to them i think
does that make sense i mean we can
certainly if when we bring the
papers back hopefully we will have made
sufficient progress
that we will have some very keen gps who
are wanting to come and
um talk to you about the progress we're
making and i i
do do know some of the gps in the north
are very very committed to this agenda
so i'm sure that next time if we talk to
um mark and
um jane obviously already has a lot of
contacts with many of the gps
and we can think about who who would who
would um be interested in coming
um to the meeting because i i'm i'm sure
that there will be a number of gps who'd
be very happy to come and talk
thank you very very much um could i just
um clarify just to make sure
we know would you do you think it'd be
useful to come back in six months or do
you feel you need a longer period of
time
for anything to kind of happen i
i think with this because of the
recovery phase i mean hopefully we could
perhaps send you a
written update in six months and come
and come to scrutiny in a year
that that would be um so that you can
then at least have something written
then you can see whether we're making
the progress that you're expecting us to
be making
but the other thing as well we can um we
can obviously as
um jilla and jane start developing the
plans further
we're always very happy to discuss any
of those with counsellors
um and so do let us know thank you
thank you very much really really
welcome that thank you so much so
thank you again for everybody's
contribution really appreciate your time
and and wish you a good evening thank
you thank you
okay so moving on to agenda item
six which was um this time looking at
health inequalities in terms
of housing and i gather that um
one of our executive members is it um
is going to give a short presentation
it's all right
yeah thanks jared it's me
thank you i think uh adrian's going to
attempt to share his screen uh
in a minute which i think he's had some
issues doing with zoom
in the past so just bear with us a
second
hey chair i will try and do that now and
hope that it works for us
wow
can we see that
yeah yes
it worked first time i'm quite impressed
okay
well thanks chair for inviting me along
to um
to just give you a brief summary of the
report and
and discuss the issues that you wanted
um discussing
um we we absolutely do have a
a quite a severe housing crisis in
trafford
um and um the current
state of plays the the average house
costs um well the average house costs on
average the eight times the salary
of the average wage in trafford um
and that is not a sustainable picture
for us to stay
in and we uh we we need to do something
about it
uh adrian you wanna move on to the the
first slide um
so that everyone can
just visualize what we're talking about
of course that's not going to work now i
assume no it's not working um
keep trying it it's fine don't worry
so um just just a few things that we
um we have been trying to do to tackle
the housing crisis and improve
um access to social and affordable
housing in the borough
um you may or may not be aware that we
created the
affordable housing fund back in 2018
which is um utilizing to
uh to our best ability the section 106
money oh here we go
i think we can we can see some
information on screen here now which is
great
um with the information on screen simply
gives you
an idea as to how many people are on a
currently you know on a housing register
and what particular bun they are in
waiting for um
accommodation within the social rented
sector
um just going back to what i was talking
about in relation to
the affordable housing fund which is
mentioned at the bottom of this
particular slide
we we created this fund in 2018
to uh make best use of the section 106
money that we get contributions from
developers
um and and the main aim of that scheme
is to provide
a grant effectively a grant basis for
housing associations uh to build
socially rented properties in the
borough
and the first of those schemes is
due to come to fruition this year in
simply uh through trafford housing trust
um who are building 30 uh apartments
um on on the broomwood in simply
so we we're really happy about that but
it is just a start and it
is only 30. we've got a hell of a way to
go
um if you want to move on adrian
um what we have
what we have done i mean it's it's one
of our major corporate priorities
increasing social and affordable housing
as as a council
and what we have done is uh create a
much more robust
viability procedure with developers
to make sure that developers are
contributing
uh what they should be contributing to
affordable and socially rented
properties as part of their developments
and we always have a preference for
on-site
development rather than off-site
financial contributions
towards um towards that and
and that's paid off um since 2017 as you
can see on the slide there
uh a total of 482 additional affordable
housing units have been negotiated
through the planning process
which equates to a monetary value of
38.5 million pounds
um the draft local plan which is
currently out for consultation as well
um aims to provide a for 40 affordable
homes
um on schemes of 10 units or more across
the borough
and and that's going to be our um
our working number going forward
it's also worth noting before we just
discuss energy efficiency
um that um in just a few weeks now we
are bringing
our um housing housing options team
in trafford back in house from salex
homes and that's no reflection
on selling zones in the slightest it
just
effectively confirms our commitment to
doing something about the housing crisis
and bringing them back in health so we
can
properly solve that situation
sorry carry on adrian you can move on um
the the next slide just provides some
information about energy efficiency in
homes
we obviously do have a slight issue with
well we have quite a major issue with
that in trafford because of the style of
the
properties that have been built and we
are working with
um our registered providers in relation
to
improving energy efficiency in homes and
that includes
uh just to give you two examples uh sail
west
um valley are doing some significant
improvements
to their homes uh over there and that
will that will include energy efficiency
work and the same goes by for your
housing in partington which is in my
ward
who are improving the the stock there to
improve the energy efficiency and tackle
fuel poverty
but this particular slide just gives you
some further statistics about
um the challenges we face i suppose
uh and and the final slide is just in
relation to fuel poverty which
um as you can see there we are on
average we have ten 10
10 of um of our households are in
are in clusters in fuel poverty um
in our borough um and and fuel poverty
um obviously it is related to um
conditions of housing but fuel poverty
obviously goes much
much further beyond that um and
um and without um
and i don't know if there is any
statistics here in particular
adrian because i couldn't i'm not sure
if already on the full report
um but the uh the breakdown between
fuel poverty and privately rented and
socially rented sector
i'm i've always thought it'd be a useful
statistic to gather together if we've
not already done it
um because the cost of private renting
is obviously
considerably higher than socially rented
properties
and the impact therefore on fuel pure
fuel poverty is likely to be far larger
um but i'm sure that's something we can
work on in the future
thanks chair happy to take any questions
thank you very much uh councillor ryan
thank you also for the
very detailed report it was um very
interesting reading reading
and all the information that was
provided so thank you very much indeed
for that
um are there any questions uh from
members of committee council akanola
sorry i haven't got the facility to put
the hand up of
right in the thing i don't know why um
yeah just a
couple of questions it's um there was a
few things i didn't quite understand
like
how many developers have we got in the
developer forum because really other
than trafford health of
uh trafford housing trust in erwell
valley
is the many that are actually included
in it
this the forum that was set up in 2019
uh yeah the the thanks to the question
uh comes right now there are a
considerable
amount of registered providers in the
in the forum i i don't know the number
off the top of my head but
the last meeting that i attended there
was at least um
eight representatives from eight
different housing associations across
trafford
and are they coming forward with um
ideas and plans for more
social housing rather than just
affordable housing
you know i've got beamy bonnet about it
i do and so do i to that
to that matter uh sorry chair sorry
apologies for jumping in there
um i yeah i mean i think all
registered providers want to build
social housing the the issue we've got
um not not just in this borough but
nationally
is social housing is very expensive to
build um
and that is the cost the cost of land
the lack of grant from governments and
afraid anymore
means that building social housing costs
a considerable amount of money
and um the encouragement over the past
at least three to four years has been
for us to concentrate on an affordable
home such as affordable rent or shared
ownership um which is
which is cheaper to build but doesn't
doesn't solve the housing crisis at its
um
at its edge really um and um
and that's it's a national issue really
more than the local issue
sorry i've got a couple of questions is
that okay and
the other one was um talking about
affordable housing in the report on page
32 it talked about
um it being based on 25 of income being
spent on housing so therefore it should
be 521 pound
sort of the base rate for affordable
rent
but in trafford i know in old trafford
on this road
this house is going from between 850
and um 1200
and i'm just wondering how are we ever
going to get to address
those issues when we've got so many
people waiting on housing lists
property being so expensive and
practically zilch being built in old
trafford yeah old trafford is very
very popular
um in relation to uh how we get to that
point
we obviously need to build more social
housing but
the i mean an easy this year and this is
not a uh not something we can do locally
by any stretch of imagination but my
personal view and always has been
um that given the state of the privately
rented market at the moment that we need
to be looking at i'm afraid
some kind of rank capping in the private
rented sector
um because and we are not going to be
able to
build enough socially rented homes to
solve the private sector housing
issues quickly enough so we need to do
something at the other end of the market
in my view
um we um we do have plans
to build more social housing and
affordable housing in old trafford
um and there are developments coming
over the hill i don't know whether
adrian you've got anything on that you
on off the top of your head that you
wanted to add there
um uh yes so thank you councilwriter and
yes chair the um there are you've
probably seen the graph in the report
and you
you see the dilemma then that probably
one of the areas the most acute
affordable need we've actually had
relatively limited um delivery and and
that's largely because
uh the sites haven't been coming forward
historically
but the good news is that um uh there
are a lot more now in the pipeline so
uh for example have the bakery site at
elsinore road
which was approved with um affordable
housing
and we understand negotiations are
underway for potentially more affordable
housing to go on to that site
um and then the council also itself of
course has been
instrumental in a number of areas in
that location so we have
um the former kellogg's headquarter site
where
there's a joint venture with bruntwood
and that has a strong uh affordable
element
and we also have a joint venture
underway um uh with trafford housing
trust on the
tamworth site which is just off charlton
road
so there are quite a number of of of
sites that are now coming forward and
part of the answer i think is is as well
as i suppose
maximizing those opportunities is also
about uh regeneration because
you know we won't get um uh the housing
built if
if people uh you know if we're not
active in regenerating
and place making and it's
it's good to see that more and more
interest is being expressed in
developments
in the north of the borough and that
gives us the opportunity in turn for
more affordable housing it is it's
i think of those schemes i think is
there only tamworth that's actually
going to have any houses on it though
aren't the rest all
high blocks which again i mean
it's balancing that thing between
housing needs that people need
and what people want for families and
i'm sorry just i don't want to dominate
just one other quick question because
is how do you gather your information
regarding
you know like um the um
the state of housing and you know the
decent home standards
have been about thermal comfort and
efficiency how do you actually get that
information because as a resident here
i've never had any sort of farm or
questionnaire and i'm one of those
people who fills in questionnaires
to ask me about the state of my housing
or anything else and i'm just interested
in how you gather that information
i think i'll refer to adrian on that one
if you don't mind thank you so nice
right and and thank you very
counsellor um yeah it is it is by
sampling i mean
clearly you could uh do a a complete
borough wide survey
um um but you know we only have to look
to the census
to to understand the logistics of that
so customarily
this is done through through sampling
and it gives us
hopefully a robust sample of different
types of properties
and from that you obviously have to make
assumptions about the overall
uh stock condition so we have a stock
condition survey and that provides the
baseline
for them making assumptions uh around uh
the picture across the borough as a
whole okay
thank you i'll show up now uh
our next question is councillor chilton
please
chairman um i have three
if i may but i'll ask them in quick
succession well it's more of an
observation in one
state um obviously it's not just the
social rented sector that's a problem
for first-time buyers who are local
people
um as i've just discovered recently to
my cost you have to be a russian
oligarch to afford a
property in especially in the south of
trafford if you happen to be from there
which is causing real problems i i don't
expect councillor right you all have an
answer to that it's the market and it's
a major problem and i don't think any of
us have
but it's a point and it's something that
also needs thinking about
um but as regards um development as well
um a recent something i've been doing in
a
with a different hat on recently is
speaking to a lot of social
and housing providers particularly those
seeking to develop new properties
one problem that they often find is that
under section 106 agreements when they
are
offered properties within sites um
you know large-scale development sites
i've actually had some developers not
local ones in trafford or grant you
who've said they've actually refused
them or had to refuse them because the
properties
that they're offered are such poor spec
in terms of
space standards this that and the other
um that they're obviously an
afterthought
um and and they wouldn't put people in
them
um so that is a problem that i'm not
sure if you've encountered thus far
but may do in the future um and just
thirdly on existing properties
this is a major issue i mean councillor
wright and i've had this discussion in
the past
about a certain social landlord you've
mentioned previously that's the cause of
many of the grey hairs i've got
where unfortunately and of course the
disrepair issues
do affect people's health you know
you've got mold growing up the walls
you've got the kitchens going green and
unfortunately
i mean there's nice noises from the
government in the recent white paper
but there's nothing concrete to compel
particularly
social landlords with a large stock
across large areas
to get them to cooperate with local
authorities where there are specific
issues
as i've found for the past 10 years and
frankly i've heard all this before from
one's particular housing association
um more observations and questions chair
but uh councillor i may wish to comment
thank you very much
councillor wright thank you chair and
thank you councillor chilton for your uh
questions i agree i mean
as a first-time buyer myself it is
almost impossible
to to buy in this borough
as we without without some form of
large inheritance or by saving up for
years and years and years
um it's it's it's it's it's almost
impossible you know
even a five percent deposit in on the
average
house price is getting on for 20 000
quid these days and
you know the the likelihood of if you've
been able to get a mortgage on a five
percent
uh deposit is highly unlikely um that i
mean the
affordable uh the the affordable uh
housing structure is there to help
first-time buyers and we do we obviously
it it's striking a balance because
we don't have enough social housing um
to help the people who are either
without a home at all
or are just a poor or disabled or ill
or whoever needs social housing and we
don't have
um enough affordable properties for
people who just want to take that first
step on the ladder
so it's striking a balance between the
social rented sector
and the affordable housing sector which
of course includes shared ownership
uh the shared ownership models the rent
to home buy models et cetera et cetera
so
you know we have to strike a balance
between the two but then we also have to
play that off of course against
things such as energy efficiency because
if we want to build zero carbon homes
that costs as well so we've got you know
to i'd love to i'd love us to be able to
deliver a scheme at what at some point
that includes
zero carbon homes socially rented homes
and affordable homes in the same place
whether we will ever get to that point
is another matter but i'd love to be in
that position
the second point you just made about the
rp's not taking
um not taking properties off developers
um it's not something i've come across
particularly but what you did mention in
relation to space standards
uh that is something that we are dealing
with through the local plan
um as we speak so we will be adopting
the national space standards
um as part of the local plan so that
um so so as trafford it has to be it
wouldn't pass through a planning
application
obviously if he didn't um didn't go
through that
um so therefore he wouldn't be offered
to the rp in the first place
uh but it is slightly concerning and
obviously uh councillor chelsea if you
do come across
anything within this borough then please
please let me know um and
um and thirdly just in relation to
disrepair
i think it again it's it's striking a
balance we do have
uh we do have more we do have a
challenge between the responsiveness
of certain um registered providers in
the borough
on uh doing the work that's needed to be
done should we say
um and uh but the regulation is fairly
weak
um and um without
national intervention i think we're
going to struggle a little bit on that i
don't know whether adrian you wanted to
come in with any more
technical details on that one
uh yeah thank you councillor um no i
think
one of the issues is that uh whilst we
have a um
legislation that we we regularly use on
this
um it is um really geared towards the
hardest cases and
and the you know the really shockingly
bad uh accommodation and there we can
step in and
we regularly do that i i think the the
issue is is is where you have
uh i perhaps have a lower level of
perhaps poor performance which obviously
is
is you know has an impact unquestionably
on on people living there
i think that's harder to address because
it's harder for us to
to prove that under the legislation that
it's really you know unfit
and therefore we start taking
affirmative action so
as you say that's really it's a
partnership approach
that we need to to to use i mean
generally
most um registered providers probably
have slightly better stock than
some of um certainly some of the older
private stock
but but not universally and and where
there are bad cases we obviously need to
highlight that
and just persevere i think
okay thank you so much councillor
hartley
thank you chair um cancer chilton has
just asked one of the questions that i
had actually
about repairs and i you know i would
echo that if you see you know if you
go around a lot of social housing that
is what residents um
complain complain about so uh i think
that's been covered already
so i had i had two sort of other areas
to ask
about i'll try and roll some of the
questions together that i had
i suppose i suppose one is about is
about building the affordable housing
council rights um
you mentioned mentioned quite a bit
about this already
um i know i know the aspiration is is
40 affordable housing but we we very
rarely see that our planning committee
and i know
planning officers work really hard to to
you know to up the contribution
so so part of my question is you know
how how can we get to that
to that 40 aspiration and
and the other thing that's surprising
when the report is really is really
useful actually particularly around
affordability
i think um you know the affordability
problem is actually
most acute in old trafford if you're
looking at rental properties um
so that's really revealing to me i
suppose the other point around
affordable housing is is again what we
see in planning committee is
you know big developments that come
forward and there's always a lot of
a lot of mention that there's a big
demand for three and four bedroom houses
and i'm sure there isn't traffic and uh
but i'm guessing that's
private um not affordable housing demand
and actually the demand um you know the
housing list figures that you can see in
the report
two thousand seven hundred of three
thousand three hundred after a one or
two bedroom
house so i suppose my first question is
around
getting getting that sort of housing
built and it also tends to be
the same house builders the same
developers and
i'm so what my question is around how
can we get more innovation
into the house building that we see in
trafford so we can
deliver those one two-bedroom homes that
we need in big numbers
and that also touches on sustainability
as well which you know you mentioned
cancer right
and that is expensive but it's happening
elsewhere so you know in norwich there
was a
development that was built to passive
health standards and it was new social
housing
uh and it was prior it was you know
award-winning design you know
it was really great so how herald
authorities
you know doing that so it's really
around getting the right housing built
and innovation
in the in the sort of house building
sector to to get more of what we want
rather than an estate with lots of three
and four bedroom houses
uh yeah thank you councillor hartley
just on the uh just to begin with the 40
aspiration it's a negotiation obviously
with
the uh with the developers as as you're
aware and
um we absolutely we've not
we've not just put a 40 as a figure in
the local plan because
you know it sounds good we really want
to get there
um i think the um
the issues we have in trafford i mean
the cost of landing trafford number one
is is eye watering um
often uh developers will go into these
negotiations
um offering zero um to be perfectly
honest um
and um they will also have almost
certainly in many and in many cases
overpaid for the land as well
so we're starting out in a very
difficult position
um however
my uh my instincts and i think the
figures also prove that is that we
absolutely are moving in the right
direction um
we have obviously we've had 38 million
pounds worth of
extra affordable housing come through
the viability process
um since 2017 and
developers are getting it they're not
they're not coming to the table
as much as they were with poor offers
of affordable housing and um we've got
developments that potential developments
coming in the pipeline that
i can't go into any detail about tonight
that
are offering us above and beyond that
figure potentially
as things stand um so i'm confident we
will get there
i'm not saying we will get there for
every development because as you said
about
striking a balance between um between
affordable housing and
zero carbon i think is going to be
something that we have to have a
discussion about going forward
um because that's another priority and
and you mentioned about the passive
house
standards um we were actually prior to
covid and adrian may remember this
um adrian um we were in
we were having just some discussions
with a and he would not signed any
anything or
you know any agreements or anything but
we were looking at a particular
house developer in um in new markets in
cambridge here
who develop their properties off-site to
a zero-carbon standard which reduces the
cost
of the homes um and
um as as an option to to go down the
zero carbon route um and um
unfortunately because of kobe that's
sort of all
um went by the bike that's something
we're going to um
revitalize and look into it in a lot
more detail as thing goes on but there's
all sorts of different ways that we can
we can do it and and to and it doesn't
necessarily have to cost
the earth but there is definitely going
to be a
trade-off between in my view how much
affordable housing we can get on a
particular site
and um how much zero carbon
we can what we can do as well and then
just in relation to the
um innovation uh we are
and adrian may be able to talk more
about this as well we are
in the in the process of producing a
design
guide um for um for for our planning
service
which will we will hope will um
uh move us in and move us to an innocent
innovative
way of building homes because um
you know social and affordable housing
doesn't have to be flat pack
and um undesirable it can be a lot
better than that and we must strive
to make it better than it is at the
moment um that is for sure but
i'll let adrian come in if he wants to
with anything extra
on those questions thanks yeah thank you
council right
um yes it is i think certainly the
design guide which hopefully will
be um coming to uh committees later in
the year
um that is certainly one way i think
where we would see
uh promoting innovation um and
i think also some of the uh council's
own development schemes that we were
um have highlighted again if we can sort
of lead the way
so those are if you like the the the
carrots in the process
um but i think realistically we also
need a few sticks and i think that's
where the local plan can come in
in terms of uh raising the bar and
obviously
we need that process to complete and we
need
the plan to be adopted but that can
start to
influence um designs and standards and
also mix
because i think that's um
there is often the sense that there's a
perhaps a mismatch between what
what gets uh built or proposed and
and what is needed and and that's
certainly in those areas of mixes where
we can start
making a difference and as council right
um
highlighted you know we didn't cover it
in the report but
but the idea of system building is
really
one i'm sure we're going to hear a lot
more of because if you consider the
the way we build houses is is largely
unchanged for about 150 years
uh and there aren't many manufacturing
processes
that we carry out today that that are
still you know
um uh as old as as sad
so you know there is there is the
opportunity for innovation
and i think the the thing we've got to
look at for that is
is quality and durability but
unquestionably as
um we we recover and we will have
more emphasis on zero carbon then
i'm sure there'll be a lot more of that
and it will be better as well
does that answer all of your questions
counselor hartley it
it well it does i had one more question
which is a lot more focused
uh if if i'm a conscious of time
really really brief as we're very very
close towards the end of the meeting
thank you yeah of course so
the other question i had was just around
whether we have any sense of
they said there's a table in the report
that has
numbers of affordable completions and uh
permissions granted
which is incoming uh sort of affordable
housing stock do we have any sense of
affordable housing that might be leaving
the stock through right
by and uh you know and other initiatives
do we have any sort of
figures locally on how that might be
taking stock out of the
affordable housing um sort of pots if
you like
pretty sure we do have those figures uh
hardly adrian
yes we will we will be able to get those
and and yes i'm sorry we've not
presented them to
uh here but of course you're quite
writers uh that's the other factor in
all this is that for various reasons
including right to buy
you we also lose stock so we have to
make sure we're replenishing
uh uh and getting the whole picture when
we when we want to consider
our affordable housing base
thank you okay thank you uh counselor
taylor please thank you council barclay
um i know this is it's slightly off
topic but um thinking about the private
rented sector really
particularly um well i think we've got a
lot of private rented property all over
the the borough but there's a lot
in um in our ward in old trafford a very
variable quality
and um it is a common issue with with
residents about the quality of the
property the maintenance of the property
and the way that landlords respond to
that and i know
private rented tenants have very very
few rights really and there's very
little in law
to to protect them
and i know we've talked about having uh
maybe a private rented charter
um within this borough and i don't think
that's something i know there's
that you can they can have database
can't at all there's databases of rogue
landlords that
um local authorities can administer but
is that something we
we have or we can implement to protect
those in private rented property because
they are extremely vulnerable
um with very little redress really to
the law
thanks councillor taylor oh it's quite
timely actually because i have a meeting
on uh landlord
licenses tomorrow believe it or not
you've timed that to perfection that
question um i am going to refer to
adrian for this one on the technical
aspects of
landlord licensing and um and such
um so if uh adrian to give us a bit more
detail on that thanks
yeah so thank you council um yes
certainly um i mean something that as
you said heard
we're looking at is landlord
accreditation
because um i suppose that hopefully
gives a means of giving confidence to
people
the the issue uh with those types of
schemes though
of course is that the what tends to
happen is that the good
landlords uh will join uh
and the poor ones won't um um but at
least it
you know if it can build momentum then
um
it is certainly a means of of i suppose
exposing those people who
who aren't if you know if you have a
scheme people aren't on it then people
can start saying well why not
uh and that might give some indications
to the quality of the housing
the other thing we can look at is um has
is multiple occupation as well
and there are a few things we can do
around the planning system not
it's only really about new ones um
and um so there are there is a little
bit more that we can do there
potentially
so you're right i think also that there
aren't
the tools aren't huge in this area but
we can certainly try
a few more things okay
thank you yeah it is it's a massive
concern and we see a lot of poor quality
housing you know
and i know you said a lot of housing in
trafford is
is sort of post second world war i think
particularly in our part of the borough
there's a lot of very old property
probably
over 100 years old you know which is in
a poor state of repair
um and again it's it's the same
same sort of population of poor um
vulnerable individuals who often are are
sort of forced into those situations
because they're the only rents that are
not even affordable but you know
remotely accessible really
and so you know it's a it's a it's a
layered up
it's a it's a multiple insult of
inequality really isn't it
poor housing and um uh
and poverty really yeah if i may chair
just to stay on that we we
to salt the private rented sector is not
going to be sold unless we have an
unless we have a national uh change of
policy it's as simple as that we if we
need to bring in more regulation
nationally to
to enable us to do something about that
particular market
and it's not just the cost of renting
it's the standard of standard of homes
and
energy efficiency and and disrepair etc
so
we need a national move to to do
something about that properly we can
tinker at the edges locally
um but without that power we we we are
limited
okay thank you very much councillor
acton please
thank you chair um my question really
was about disabilities
um obviously we are talking about health
inequalities tonight and i didn't see
anywhere in the report or in the
presentations
around people with disabilities and
how we're actually working to provide
better standards for people with
disabilities
and whether we do that through um
developers or or our planners um
you know i just wonder you know what's
the thinking in relation to that
thanks councillor axe and you'll be
pleased to know um the the
accessibility and improving um improving
tenancies and properties for for
disabled people
is um a quite a large part of our local
plan
which is currently under consultation as
we speak at the moment
and it is quite a detailed um
piece of work within that local plan
that explains what our aims and
objectives are going to be to improve um
not just existing properties but also
taking disability into into account as
part of the planning process to make
sure that we try and build
more accessible homes from the beginning
rather than trying to retrofit them
at a later stage which often costs far
more money than it
that than it needs to do if they're
already built to the accessible
standards so
if you if you have a if you have a look
at our local plan um
it's quite easy to read and quite easy
to find there's there's quite a lot of
detail in there for you to
to have a look at thank you
thank you councillor right and cancer
children you wanted to come back with a
question
i would always point people to that as
an example of how it should be built
um often the structure the internal
external immunity space
mean excellent for people's well-being
quite often it's from the sort of mid to
late 1960s onwards
where they were throwing stuff up on the
cheap and it's
really badly affected people's health
and well-being
but so i mean i will always say the past
you know
quite often bad and has been a problem
but there are also examples of good
practice
thank you
okay thank you councillor chilton and
thank you so much for all your questions
just a real quick one just to finish
from me if i if i met you if your
committee would allow me
and i really like the list you know the
availability of all the schemes that are
available
for heating repairs and boiler repairs i
think there was a list at the end
of your report the lad scheme seemed to
have really good publicity around it and
it seemed to be
well advertised i just wondered whether
um
the schemes that were listed with them
there's a whole range of them whether
they receive the same kind of
publicity and awareness within our uh
our
borough because obviously it's really
important that they reach um
the people who actually need them so i
just wondered are they as well
publicized how are we doing how are we
making sure
that the people who need the repairs the
most who are most vulnerable most you
know
unable to afford them themselves are
they finding out about these schemes and
are you actually
collecting information on that and how
do we compare
in terms of other gm councils on that
thank you
good question uh chair thank you for
that i'm probably going to refer to
adrian on that one who may be able to
answer now or may be able to
get the information to you uh following
this uh meeting thank you
yes thank you chair and and um yes so
the
we we will try and uh obviously public
publicize those
as much as we can um and
you know as broadly as possible i think
in terms of the
in terms of the take up and the
comparison with um
uh other gm districts uh i think we will
probably be able to get that information
and certainly that's
uh hopefully perhaps something that we
can um uh
send to you separately if that would be
of assistance
thank you i mean what how do you feel
that we do we are doing with those i
mean do you think the take-up is good
um or do you feel that we're lagging
behind it
um well on some of some of the schemes
obviously some of the schemes that the
the sums involved are fairly modest uh
sadly
um i think we overall
compared with greater manchester we are
we are fortunate you know our housing
stock is
is is better we have um you know that's
not to disregard the problems that we
we have but i think if we compare
ourselves
within greater manchester we would fare
fairly well
i think the perhaps the better
comparison or perhaps the other
comparison you can look at is
is nationally um and and generally
we we we perhaps you know there are
clearly other parts of the country where
our conditions and our take up is is is
much less
and so i suppose if we on that bus take
the view that well
we're doing quite well we're doing
reasonably but there's more we can do
and i think that's
um you know that's probably i i how i
would characterize our position
um but certainly i think amongst our gm
peers we're certainly
um doing as well as well as any okay
thank you very much and thank you nice
to meet you ask that question can we see
okay
so thank you so much we have reached
really the end of our meeting in fact
we've uh
extended it a little to incorporate all
the questions
uh really like to thank you very very
much uh for
um answering all of our queries just a
couple of things in terms of follow-up
for
the future and it would be really really
uh welcome i think members of committee
would welcome
um a future update and maybe you can
determine
with us what timing that should be but a
written update on the progress towards
numbers of affordable
houses that are being built uh within
the borough
uh also uh following on from councillor
taylor's uh suggestion
uh progress on your landlord
accreditation
scheme that you're looking into and
shortly and also
could we have an update on the
improvements that are going to be made
within the planning process for hmos
because they are that is really
important as well i think
and again finally just and could we have
a little bit more reassurance and
information around how you're
publicizing those schemes for
repairs for heating and boilers because
we do want to
be reassured that you know the
information is reaching all sectors and
of our of our borough and so would that
be um something that you could come back
to committee with maybe with a written
document written update would that be
acceptable
yeah that sounds fine to me chair um i
would say
the uh report on the first thing you
asked for which is a
delivery of affordable housing probably
worth doing 12 monthly
um the others i'm sure we could
certainly do earlier than that
thank you fantastic thank you very much
i really appreciate your contributions
to the evening thank you so much for
attending thank you and good evening
okay
so um just carrying on with our just
finishing our agenda
i don't think we have any urgent
business louis fabian
uh no no no urgent business sure
okay okay and there's nothing under
agenda agenda item with the
exclusion resolution okay fantastic
so we have reached the end of our
meeting and thank you to
everybody for attending and for fabiola
the amazing support that she gives us
with it thank you to all our
presenters executive members council
officers thank you
for all the time you've given up and
making them you know writing the reports
and presenting to us
and answering all our questions and also
want to thank
members of committee this is our last
meeting of the municipal year
we've only had two meetings it's been a
short and hopefully uh productive uh two
meetings
and there's lots of um ideas to
follow-ups obviously things emerging
from this meeting and our previous
meeting
that a future committee can decide to
follow up on
uh but it's great that we do have
commitment from our presenters to bring
back information
into your course and just wish everybody
um really good
few months and um we obviously don't
know the composition of the committee
for future but thank you very much for
everything you've done
this year thank you does committee have
anything they'd like to mention
no okay so thank you chair you've been
an excellent chair this
year very difficult circumstances so
thank you very much
thank you thank you to everyone and
thank you fabiola for the amazing
support you've given
over the years so wish you all um good
evening and see you soon